- Welcome to the Kelly
Clarkson Show everybody.
(crowd cheering)
We've got a special hour ahead for you.
These past couple weeks
we've been celebrating
all the joy and merriment of the season.
You don't get to say
merriment a lot, you know?
We do here.
We've got lots of cool guests for everyone
from former First Lady Michelle Obama
to Dolly Parton, to Amy Poehler.
(crowd cheering)
Everyone has had so much
holiday goodness to share.
We just haven't had enough airtime
for all of it 'cause I'm chatty.
But that doesn't seem right.
So today we've got a festive gift for you.
This is a Kelly extra
helping of Christmas.
(crowd cheering)
(Christmas music)
And it wouldn't be the Kelly Clarkson show
if we didn't start with music.
So let's begin with the Kellyoke encore.
This is me and my band
y'all with Last Christmas.
It's a bonus song from last year's
Holiday Spectacular
Kelly Clarkson presents
when Christmas comes around.
(crowd cheering)
(soft piano music)
♪ Last Christmas I gave you my heart ♪
♪ The very next day you gave it away ♪
♪ This year, to save me from tears ♪
♪ I'll give it to someone special ♪
♪ Last Christmas I gave you my heart ♪
♪ But the very next day you gave it away ♪
♪ This year, to save me from tears ♪
♪ I'll give it to someone special ♪
♪ Once bitten and twice shy ♪
♪ I keep my distance, but
you still catch my eye ♪
♪ Tell me baby, do you recognize me ♪
♪ It's been a year, it
doesn't surprise me ♪
♪ Last Christmas I gave you my heart ♪
♪ The very next day you gave it away ♪
♪ You gave it away ♪
♪ This year, to save me from tears ♪
♪ I'll give it to someone special ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
(soft piano music continues)
♪ Merry Christmas, I
wrapped it up and sent it ♪
♪ With a note saying "I
love you", I meant it ♪
♪ Now I know what a fool I've been ♪
♪ But if you kissed me now,
I know you'd fool me again ♪
♪ Last Christmas I gave you my heart ♪
♪ The very next day you gave it away ♪
♪ This year, to save me from tears ♪
♪ I'll give it to someone special ♪
♪ Last Christmas I gave you my heart ♪
♪ But the very next day you gave it away ♪
♪ This year, to save me from tears ♪
♪ I'll give it to someone special ♪
(crowd cheering and applauding)